[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today's topic is Jamaican Creole also
known as patois Jamaica is an island
nation in the Caribbean with a
population of only around 3 million
people but it's made a cultural impact
around the world because of its art
forms such as reggae and dancehall music
as well as dub poetry many English
speakers have had the experience of
hearing someone from Jamaica speak and
understanding a little bit of it but not
most of it I mean ah why them people are
really really pious tickle-tickle when I
flew in on I'm out Ellis a yeah luckily
me lick me I tell us my Seraphina lip it
me god no that's because patois partly
descended from English but not entirely
it's an english-based creole language
that developed in the 17th and 18th
centuries through contact between
African slaves and english-speaking
slave owners the island of Jamaica was
first colonized by the Spanish who
brought the first African slaves there
and enslaved the native tyno people
until they were wiped out by violence
and disease but it was after the island
was taken over by Britain in the year
1655 that the African population rapidly
grew as the British brought slaves from
West Africa to work on sugar cane
plantations these Africans were
intentionally separated from others who
spoke the same language as them so they
wouldn't be able to communicate in
secret and plan a rebellion with no
common language they did their best
under harsh conditions to use the
English dialects spoken by their slave
masters they didn't learn the language
formally and they had to learn the
language very quickly which resulted in
the development of a pidgin language
they adopted a basic vocabulary of
English words and strung them together
using a simplified form of the grammar
of their native languages eventually
when they had children those children
learned the simple pidgin language as
their native language but expanded its
features and use making it a living
language used for all parts of life that
was when the pidgin language became a
creole language the term patois comes
from French and can be used generally to
refer to any kind of non-standard speech
but it's also how Jamaicans refer to
their creole language not altered
in Padua is the same there are various
regional and local varieties around the
island one reason is that the slave
owners spoke various different dialects
of English another reason is the
mountainous terrain and isolation of the
different plantations and communities
from each other when a pidgin language
becomes a Creole it becomes more complex
and new features arise to make the
language sufficient for everyday use
that means that in communities isolated
from each other the new features might
have been different also the official
language of Jamaica is not patois but
English and patois has spoken on a
continuum with standard Jamaican English
that means that in some situations some
speakers will essentially be speaking
standard English with a
characteristically Jamaican accent while
in other situations some speakers will
mix English with varying degrees of
patois and at a very casual end of the
spectrum speakers might use Jamaican
Patois
exclusively in technical terms pure
patois is the Basile act while standard
English is the acro left and in the
middle lies the mezzo lect the acro
elect standard english is the prestige
language and the language of social
mobility while patois is sometimes
considered to be incorrect English or
improper speech but patois is a distinct
language with its own phonology grammar
and vocabulary distinctions there's also
another form of patois called crow Monty
or deep patois which was used by the
Maroons descendants of slaves who
escaped from the Spanish when the
British invaded Jamaica and set up
communities deep in the mountains this
form of patois is more heavily based in
the akan language than other forms of
patois deep patois is now used as a
ritual language in maroon communities
but not as a daily spoken language
vocabulary the majority of patois
vocabulary comes from English but with
pronunciation that has diverged widely
from English there's technically no
standard way to write patois only
general tendencies but those differences
from English are usually reflected in
patois spelling for example somebody
somebody something Sultan money money
market market here ear open open this
this with wit notice that the Sun and
the sounds of English th don't exist in
Jamaican Patois while these spellings
may look strange
to people who know standard English
they're actually phonetic
representations of speech unlike English
spelling which was basically frozen in
time several hundred years ago and
sometimes doesn't reflect current
pronunciation sometimes words that have
a final consonant cluster in English
lose a consonant in patois
for example respect respect you'll
notice that the words are often used
differently love from English enough
means many or much not respect this
means much respect
chut is used as the general word for
speak or talk make from English make is
used generally for causative meaning
like both make and let in English let me
tell you something meaning let me tell
you something and notice here there's a
different variant of the word meaning
something there are also lots of words
that are created by compounding other
simple words no azole literally no soul
this means nostril on middle literally
hand middle this means the palm of your
hand
Yatta literally I water this means tear
already I literally read I this means
envious or covetous this is actually a
lone translation of a phrase in the akan
language of West Africa an ebay day and
that brings us to words that come from
languages other than English for example
the word for eat yum this word comes
from a West African language perhaps
willeth the word for ghost
dopey this comes from a con the word for
spider Anansi this also comes from a con
the word for clumsy or awkward boffin
and there's a sprinkling of words from
other languages for example the word
meaning child
Pitney which comes from the Portuguese
word bikini no a diminutive form of the
word Pokeno meaning small variations of
this particular word appear in numerous
creole languages around the world
grammar the basic word order of patois
is similar to that of standard English
for example lechuck patois this means I
speak patois the word order is subject
verb object as it is in standard English
M&M the Kea he is eating the cake again
this is SVO let's add a little more
information here M&M the Kea Guam maybe
he is eating the cake that I
this relative Clause is introduced by a
relative pronoun wah which is the
question word meaning what
in English it would be strange to use
what in this context but we might use
which notice that there's a definite
article before the word cake D this is
the equivalent of the in English there's
also an indefinite article ah which is
the obvious equivalent of standard
English ah this word here ah looks like
the indefinite article but it's not it's
the equivalent of English is in English
is before a present participle indicates
the present progressive that an action
is ongoing ah functions the same way in
patois placing it before a verb makes it
progressive instead of ah another word
day can also be used in the NAM the
kicks
this also means he's eating the cake day
comes from the Igbo language from the
word d meaning to be ah and they are
both used as the copula as well though
slightly differently from each other ah
is used for equative sentences Amada
doctor he's the doctor
day is used with allocative meaning in
other words indicating location as in
this sentence them the Arkenstone
they're in Kingston hear the word ah is
not a copula but rather a preposition
meaning in or ant with adjectives a
copula isn't needed this are bokya all
this sentence doesn't have the copula
are the equivalent of is in the standard
English translation also notice the
demonstrative pronoun D SIA which comes
from this here just this is also
possible we also see yah after book it
means here another similar sentence is
this are WA or book meaning this is an
old book in the first sentence the
adjective is the predicate so the copula
isn't needed but if the adjective is
part of a noun phrase then a copula is
used one the number one can also
function like an indefinite article in
this case it would be strange to have ah
the copula followed by the indefinite
article ah one seems a better fit here
pronouns you may have already noticed
some personal pronouns that kind of
resemble English ones the main ones are
me you him
note that in
be either masculine or feminine we know
them the most interesting pronoun here
is uno because it doesn't come from
English it comes from the Igbo pronoun
who knew note that there is no
difference between the subject pronouns
and object pronouns in patois so for
example me is the equivalent of both I
and me in English there are also no
separate forms for possessive adjectives
my car is
McKey are you simply place the same
personal pronoun before the noun for
possessive pronouns like mine in English
the preposition fee fee which means 2 or
4 is used before the pronoun not the key
are often Lea word-for-word that their
car is to me but in natural English that
car is mine the preposition fee is also
used before verbs like 2 in English in
love with big or in self he loves to
boast big up is a phrasal verb meaning
to give someone a thumbs up or show
respect to someone fee is not always
used before a verb where you would have
an infinitive in English it seems to
depend on the verb that comes before and
in some cases it seems to be optional
and since we're on the topic of verbs
there are basically no verb conjugations
in Jamaican Patois with the exception of
some words like phoebe meaning to be in
english which has a different conjugated
form but still it's only 1 conjugated
form ah so present tense verbs have just
one form regardless of the subject we
read em read as we saw before the
present progressive can be expressed by
adding ah before the verb or de emery
the book he's reading a book the past
tense is sometimes not indicated and
needs to be inferred from the context
but it can be indicated with one of
three markers when did or been in the
read a book in we read these sentences
mean he read a book in the simple past
the progressive marker are can also be
used with the past tense to express the
past progressive in when I read a book
he was reading a book Ben is more like a
present perfect progressive marker in
Ben readable this means he has been
reading a book the future is normally
expressed using the verb goal as in
English the margherita book they are
going to read the book
aggo is like are going to in English and
the future is also often expressed using
we like will in English then we read the
book they will read the book and a
different sentence since I'm tired of
talking about people reading books
John will sleep on the bed John will
sleep on that bed John will sleep on the
bed
notice here at the preposition pun which
means on or upon the word it descended
from also notice that day that they
literally that there which we saw before
notice that that day can be split by the
noun with that coming before and they're
coming after questions yes or no
questions are simple in patois you
simply raise your intonation you in raw
beach did you go to the beach we're
forward it's you
past tense marker go to beach notice
that there's no question in version or
use of did as there is in English it's
no different from the sentence meaning
you went to the beach except that it has
rising intonation and again here we see
the word ah used as a preposition
showing movement towards something like
two in English for open questions many
of the interrogative pronouns in other
words question words resemble English
ones with some phonological changes whoa
no I do what are you doing where you are
go where are you going of the book who
has the book but there are some
differences too like the way to ask why
while make from English what make Rama
keema ball why is she crying notice the
word ball which in English means to cry
loudly or uncontrollably but in patois
it just means to cry now that we've had
a look at some of the basic features of
Jamaican Patois
let's look at a couple more sentences
and see what we discover because I don't
know where my wife is
I have to go cook dinner for myself
chumina know I know wife they may offer
myself what forward it because I know
know where my wife is located I have to
go cook dinner for myself the first word
true means because and indicates the
reason for something me means I because
it's the subject in this sentence know
is the basic way of expressing a
negative as in English
in the simple present in other words for
habitual action or states no is used by
itself but with other tenses or aspects
it can combine with the tensor aspect
marker the present progressive negator
is nah a combination of no and ah the
progressive aspect marker this is also
used to express negation in the future
and also neva neva is used for the past
like never in English in the phrase me
wife me functions as a possessive
adjective like my remember that day is
the copula that is used for locative
meaning indicating location huffy means
have to a combination of half and fie
meaning to Dina means dinner and fee
meself means for myself with fee meaning
two or four and one final sentence so
I'm gonna like them people in chatty
chatty this means I don't like those
people they talk too much
word for words I know like those people
they excessively chatty in the sentence
we can see them twice but used in
different ways the first dem is a
demonstrative adjectives like those in
English in the second instance it's the
subject pronoun they dem is also used in
a different context as a plural marker
with them coming after the noun the post
boom means the cats the ears them means
my ears
notice that ears from English ears is
normally singular in patois to be made
plural it's followed by dem after that
chatty chatty chopped it Shakti this is
a redo plication of the word chatty
which means chatty reduplicating is
common in Jamaican Patois
sometimes to intensify an adjective like
in this case as you can see Jamaican
Patois is quite similar to English in
many ways and with that sliding scale
between full-on patois on the one hand
and standard English on the other
certain speakers patois is more mixed
with English than others that leads some
people to believe that patois is nothing
but English spoken with a Jamaican
accent with a little bit of slang thrown
in but the full-on patois Baz elect has
its own grammatical features its own
vocabulary and its own phonological
features that make it quite distinct
from standard English the question of
the day to anyone from Jamaica
or Jamaicans living abroad to what
extent do you use patois and to what
extent do you use standard English does
it depend on the situation and two
speakers of English native speakers or
otherwise what do you think of Jamaican
Patois how much of it are you able to
understand I'll add some links in the
description of this video so you can
hear some more real-life samples of
patois if you enjoyed this video check
out the different lengths okis social
media accounts like Facebook YouTube
Twitter Instagram etc and as always I
want to give a very special thanks to my
patreon supporters especially my top
tier patreon supporters whose names
appear right here on the screen many
special thanks to them and to everyone
thank you for watching and have a nice
day
[Music]